If you ask anyone, any person from any culture,
any part of the world, to describe what death
looks like, most people will immediately jump
to a depiction of the Grim Reaper.
And rightly so, the Reaper has long been the
personification of death and decay.
An omen of demise, the cloaked skeleton bearing
a sharp scythe, coming to collect souls and
carry them off to either Heaven or Hell.
For centuries, human beings have thought of
the Grim Reaper as death itself, but he’s
more of an embodiment of it, a symbol meant
to represent that all-too-familiar fear of
not knowing what lies beyond life on this
fragile mortal plane of existence.
Death itself, the real death, looks completely
different.
Welcome to the story of SCP-001.
Now, first things first, to anyone familiar
with the SCP Foundation, you will most likely
know that there are multiple SCP-001s.
You might even think you know which of them
is the real one.
But for those of you who are new here, allow
us to clarify for you this important context.
The designation of “SCP-001” doesn’t
refer to a single creature, object or entity,
but rather a collection of various anomalies
that are allegedly kept contained by the SCP
Foundation.
Now, there are multiple explanations as to
why these various files are all collected
under the shared designation of SCP-001.
One explanation could be that this is because
these anomalies are some of the earliest ever
contained by the Foundation.
By this rationale, all the SCP-001s share
the same designation because they were first
encountered before the SCP Foundation established
the numbering system that it currently uses.
However, there also exists a theory that this
is nothing more than intentional misdirection.
If we choose to believe this explanation,
then it could mean that the many different
SCP-001s are a devious ploy by the Foundation
themselves.
In the interest of maintaining secrecy and
security, having many files sharing the name
SCP-001 could be the Foundation’s way of
keeping the nature of the true first SCP a
closely guarded secret.
It seems plausible that the multiple SCP-001
files could be an attempt by the Foundation
to conceal information.
After all, it wouldn’t be the first time
this secretive organization deceived someone.
So, what exactly is this particularly morbid
take on SCP-001?
Well first, you have to have a pretty high
level of security clearance within the SCP
Foundation if you want to even come close
to accessing this file.
In fact, any and all details about the anomaly
codenamed Dead Men is protected by Hellenstic,
an AIC used by the Foundation’s Overwatch
Command, also known as the O5 Council.
An AIC, for those who are not yet aware, is
an advanced form of artificial intelligence
that the Foundation develops and uses to run
parts of its archive of anomalies.
What does that mean for SCP-001?
Well, it’s pretty simple: the people in
charge of the Foundation want this file to
remain secure.
Or it could be because the O5 Council is hiding
something, something that the general staff
members aren’t meant to know about.
Getting past all the
additional security surrounding
this particular file, we learn that SCP-001,
or this one at least, is...
An old man.
An 84 year old man, to be precise.
Wait, that’s it?
That’s what the big, closely guarded secret
is?
Just some old guy?
No, of course he’s not just “some old
guy”, the Foundation’s highest ranking
members wouldn’t go through such trouble
over one ordinary man.
This particular man has become one with death.
Not the Reaper, no… death itself.
The very concept of death has been merged
with this individual.
A lot more interesting than just a normal,
old man, right?
To be clear, this man is not an incarnation
or embodiment of death like the Grim Reaper.
Instead, he has become a vessel for the process
of making something that was once alive, not.
So, this old man, SCP-001, can control life
and death?
Not quite.
The old man’s body is more like a way that
death itself can be influenced.
It may help to picture it like this - Imagine
SCP-001 as a television remote control for
death.
Except instead of pressing buttons like you
would on a remote, you have to remove or alter
parts of the old man’s body.
And in doing so, you can manipulate the process
of death, albeit only to a limited extent.
You can’t, for example, permanently stop
death from existing or occurring, stopping
everyone around the world from dying.
That’s not quite how SCP-001 works.
Here, let’s give you an example.
SCP-001 had his tongue removed as well as
had sustained damage to his eardrums before
he was contained by the Foundation.
So, as a result of those alterations to his
body, there are fewer “Deals with Death”
events in the modern era.
You see what we mean now?
Changing SCP-001 changes how death functions,
but doesn’t necessarily stop it from happening.
So in essence, although there are parameters,
SCP-001 is the Foundation’s way of controlling
death itself.
How did they decide to go about doing this?
Well, once we tell you, you will understand
why the O5 Council wanted to keep information
about SCP-001 such a secret.
After performing a series of complex brain
surgeries and various other procedures on
the old man, the Overwatch Command intentionally
engineered him to be unable to perceive certain
people.
Who were those people?
You guessed it, the O5 Council themselves.
Making SCP-001 unable to recognize the faces
of any O5 Council members, means that death
is unable to see or perceive the council members
either.
All those pieces fit together
to form a particularly
unsettling jigsaw puzzle: by tampering with
SCP-001, the O5 Council have made themselves
effectively immortal.
They cannot die, nor will they age or decay
like normal, mortal human beings.
Death still occurs of course, other beings
can die, but the council members are exempt
from that fundamental law of nature.
The Foundation believes that SCP-001 was initially
created by an occult group known as The Eternal
Circle.
Thanks to records recovered from the Circle’s
London headquarters, the SCP Foundation now
knows that they were the ones responsible
for merging the old man with the concept of
death.
When their personnel first recovered SCP-001,
the old man was frail, in a poor physical
condition and barely responded to any external
stimuli.
Research staff believed he must have suffered
severe trauma at the hands of the Eternal
Circle, evidenced by the circular symbols
that had been carved into his back, oh, and
also the fact that his body parts had all
been modified.
Contained within the file for this SCP-001
is a letter directly from
the O5 Council themselves,
explaining their reasons for using the old
man to become immortal.
They justify their actions by claiming that
they have a wealth of experience in containing
anomalies and keeping the SCP Foundation running.
This is, to them, a perfectly valid reason
to make themselves exempt from death, rather
than aging, retiring and dying, to later be
replaced by new members on the Overwatch Council.
They claim that their immortality is not for
their own self benefit of course, but for
the good of the Foundation as an organization,
and by extension, the world as a whole.
The council also promised that the same death
exempt status would later be extended to other
vital members of personnel.
However, according to the Hellenstic AIC guarding
the file “No personnel have been considered
for death-exempt status in the future.”
In other words, the O5 Council were lying,
and intended to keep their Get out of Death
Free card to themselves.
It wasn’t long before the Foundation’s
very own Ethics Committee learned about what
the Council was up to, and naturally, they
had some concerns.
According to a report issued by committee
chairman Odongo Tejani, the way the O5 Council
were using SCP-001 to prolong their own lives
was immoral and inhumane, even by their own
strange standards.
By using this poor, frail old man for their
own gain, the Council had warped the natural
way death should work,
and threatened to anomalously
unbalance the very laws of nature.
The Ethics Committee had no other choice but
to dispatch its own Mobile Task Force, known
as Omega 1, or the “Law’s Left Hand”,
to rectify the situation.
Their mission?
To detain all members of the O5 Council at
their next meeting, removing them from office
and replacing them with high ranking candidates
from within the Foundation’s lower ranks.
Finally, they also planned to neutralize SCP-001,
cleaning house and removing the temptation
for future council members to make themselves
immortal.
In short, this was a coup.
The O5 Council was going to be overthrown
by their own ethics committee.
Of course, the council were more than prepared
for this, and had their very own Mobile Task
Force on hand to defend them against the plot.
Alpha 1, also known under the codename “Red
Right Hand” - the legendary lackeys of the
O5 Council - clashed with the Law’s Left
Hand.
It is believed that the shadowy Administrator
of the SCP Foundation also had his own personal
task force, possibly Rēsh 1, also called
the “Seat of Consciousness”, enter the
fray.
In other words, we were looking at an absolutely
insane three-way Foundation civil war bloodbath.
How exciting!
Security footage showed these three groups
engaged in a fire fight within Site 01, using
Foundation training and tactics against each
other in what was probably the most epic battle
of all of their lives.
It was absolute chaos - the air thick with
screams and gunsmoke.
Cameras also picked up a group of men and
women, lying all around Site 01, many wounded
but still alive.
Impressive, given how many of them had taken
gunshots right to their heads.
That’s right, these were presumed to be
the members of the O5 Council, still unable
to die despite being shot.
It is unclear which of the MTFs was responsible
for this, the Ethics Committee had only intended
Law’s Left Hand to secure the council members.
It could well be that they were caught in
the crossfire that occurred as the Law’s
Left Hand and Red Right Hand teams fought.
Unless, of course, the Administrators task
force were the ones who had stepped in and
shot the O5 Council.
Through all the chaos that had unfurled, SCP-001
was still in his cell.
And he wasn’t alone.
An unknown figure had somehow gained access,
and he conversed with SCP-001.
The man went on to tell
SCP-001 that the Foundation
was wrong to tamper with the nature of death,
and recounted a story.
He said that he had once filed paperwork regarding
anomalies for an unknown organization, but
couldn’t live with the horror of what his
job entailed.
So, the man sold these files to a group of
thirteen individuals: the O5 Council.
They then went on to form a full organization,
the SCP Foundation as we know it.
The man then stated he was disgusted with
how the Foundation had used SCP-001, how the
council members had engineered the frail,
old man to make themselves immortal.
He had hoped they would be a force for good,
keeping any necessary evil to a minimum.
The unknown figure told SCP-001 that the conflict
between the council and the Ethics Committee
had happened many times before, with many
other versions of the old man.
Earlier SCP-001s, previously merged with the
concept of death.
He then helped SCP-001 identify the members
of the council, ending their immortality,
promising the weak, tired old man that he’d
finally be able to rest.
The unknown mystery man claimed that he would
always be in power, the O5 Council would always
bring him back.
After all, he was their figurehead, their
leader, the SCP Foundation Administrator himself.
In the end, the Administrator himself chose
to let himself perish too, perhaps in shame
of what his organization had become.
Or did he?
Because someone seems to have been accessing
the Hellenstic AIC and the SCP-001 file using
his login since this incident.
Maybe the hand of death doesn’t reach quite
as far as we were led to believe.
And that’s where the tale of SCP-001 ends;
a story of the Foundation’s greed in their
pursuit of eternal life.
We mustn’t forget that death isn’t something
to be afraid of, after all, it gives our lives
meaning knowing that they’ll one day end.
But when you look at the kind of monsters
we can become in the pursuit of eternal life,
well…
In the words of another wise old man, “Sometimes,
dead is better.”
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Which is the
Real 001?” and “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks”
for more on the mysterious SCP-001!